good defensive teams are ones that are
going to have advantages because the
offense going to take a little time to
catch up
harris with a rebound of the valentine's
miss
and b did shoot 35 percent from distance
was that a three from ben simmons i i
think it was he was right on the line
where will he be where will he be used
post up on anderson earlier that's the
beauty of ben simmons the ability to
place him just about anywhere on the
floor
for a second there al had john marant no
one saw him unable to get it
uh take that let me interrupt you
because ben
simmons in rhythm hit him look at it
again here it is tobias finds him
like it's nothing fans liking it is
alex burks where he number 20 ninth year
player from colorado
11 games so far as a sixer again they
got him
from the golden state warriors there
goes matisse fiba with a
major move and slam well done by the
rookie for his first hoop
wait to your second season the first
game that's when you're officially a
second year player
but he hasn't have time to waste